sozial Tourismus ein Wort das in diesen
Stunden Wellen schlägt das wirft nämlich
CDU-Chef März Millionen von Ukrainern
vor denjenigen die vor dem Krieg ins
Ausland und unter anderem auch zu uns
nach Deutschland geflohen sind Wohnung
Geld Unterstützung vieles davon gibt es
hier tatsächlich schnell und
vergleichsweise unbürokratisch aber
deswegen gleich von sozialtourismus zu
sprechen ist natürlich sehr sehr
fragwürdig deswegen steht Friedrich Merz
in der Kritik und jetzt macht er die
Rolle rückwärts er rudert zurück und
schreibt bei Twitter jetzt das hier er
schreibt zu meinen Äußerungen von
gestern über die Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine gibt es viel Kritik ich bedauere
die Verwendung des Wortes
sozialtourismus das war eine
unzutreffende Beschreibung eines in
Einzelfällen zu beobachtenden Problems
und weiter schreibt er wenn meine
Wortwahl als verletzend empfunden wird
dann bitte ich dafür in aller Form um
Entschuldigung und zugeschaltet aus
Kiosk ist jetzt Bild Vize-Chef Paul
Ronzheimer Paul reicht dir
Entschuldigung reicht sie generell aus
ja also man muss sagen dass Friedrich
Merz jetzt nach wenigen Stunden eine
Nacht hat darüber geschlafen heute
morgen hat das dann noch selbst
getwittert offenbar zweimal dann wieder
gelöscht da muss es hin und her gegangen
sein im Konrad adenauer-haus also große
Krisenstimmung bei der CDU dass er jetzt
gesagt hat dass er sich für diesen
Begriff entschuldigt das finde ich
richtig und wichtig dass er das getan
hat denn es geht ja nicht darum das muss
man vielleicht auch mal klar sagen dass
die Probleme nicht benannt werden sollen
wenn es diese Probleme gibt also wenn
ukrainische Flüchtlinge betrügen sollten
mit Hartz IV oder anderen
Sozialleistungen dann muss das natürlich
angesprochen werden und gehört auch den
Tisch aber Friedrich Merz hat eben nicht
konkrete Zahlen oder Fälle angesprochen
sondern an er hat sehr verallgemeinern
von sozialtourismus gesprochen und damit
natürlich auch alle Ukrainer die in
diesen Wochen einen der härtesten
Momente dieses Krieges noch erleben
insbesondere im und Süden wo es heftige
Kämpfe gibt wo jeden Tag Soldaten
sterben er hat in dem Moment sozusagen
eine Verallgemeinerung gewählt die dann
für Entrüstung überall gesorgt hat nicht
nur in der sozusagen in der
ampelregierung die gegen ihn steht als
Opposition sondern auch in der eigenen
Partei und er war jetzt so unter Druck
auch aus der Öffentlichkeit dass er sich
dort entschuldigen musste ob das
wirklich seine ehrliche Meinung ist das
stellt sich ein bisschen in Frage denn
er hat ja eben heute morgen genau dieses
Wort noch getwittert dass er das jetzt
bereut Stunden später hat dann ganz
offensichtlich eben mit den harten
Reaktionen zu tun aber reicht dir das
als Entschuldigung
ich finde es reicht erstmal denn er hat
klar gemacht dass dieses Wort nicht geht
ich meine es geht jetzt ja nicht darum
dass Friedrich Merz hier irgendwie zu
Kreuze kriechen soll aber die Debatte
wird sicherlich weitergehen die Debatte
wird sein ein Oppositionsführer der so
etwas ohne überlegt ist sagt dann wenige
Stunden später das zurückziehen muss da
wird natürlich die Frage gestellt wie
erfolgreich kann so jemand dann in der
Regierung sein und was ist mit Friedrich
Merz los als
Oppositionsführer das ihm so etwas
passiert
oh du bist ein Kriegsbeginn in der
Ukraine ganz nah dran an den Menschen du
siehst das Leid vor Ort wie wirkt das in
dem Land bei den Menschen wenn der Chef
der größten Oppositionsfraktion hier in
Deutschland so einen harten Vorwurf
formuliert
das ist bislang noch nicht so richtig
angekommen hier das wird passieren in
den nächsten Stunden nehme ich an dass
das auch in den ukrainischen Medien
debattiert wird insgesamt sorgt das
natürlich nicht für ein gutes Bild
Deutschlands denn wir haben die eine
Debatte um Waffen und wenn jetzt das
dazu kommt dann fragen sich hier
natürlich viele wie kann das eigentlich
sein andre Melnik der jetzt
verabschiedete Botschafter hat er
bereits reagiert ich denke auch andere
ukrainische Politiker werden darauf
reagieren denn man muss ja eines klar
sagen hier ein Kiew wo ich gerade bin da
sind viele Menschen zurückgekommen ich
kenne viele Ukraine die nach Deutschland
geflüchtet waren und die bereits
zurückgekommen sind also anders als zum
Beispiel afghanische Flüchtlinge oder
syrischen Flüchtlinge die in Deutschland
sind und teilweise eben gar nicht zurück
können in ihrer Heimat aufgrund von
politischen Verhältnissen wollen und
können die Ukrainer zumindest hier in
die Hauptstadt teilweise zurück in
bestimmte andere Gebiete eben nicht und
da versuchen auch pro russische Trolls
pro russisch
Accounts in den sozialen Medien ja immer
sozusagen die Ukraine so darzustellen
hat sei da überhaupt gar keinen Krieg
weil hier in Kiew teilweise das Leben
ganz normal mittlerweile weitergehen
kann aber im anderen Gebieten des Landes
sieht es eben völlig anders aus der
Süden der Osten von wo wir auch immer
wieder berichten da gibt es täglich
Beschuss da stehen täglich auch
Zivilisten und es ist in einem Krieg nie
so dass das ganze Land auf einmal
betroffen war Kiew war im Februar März
April betroffen bis die Truppen dann
abzogen und dann hat sich das Leben hier
eben etwas normalisiert aber das dann
für eine Propaganda zu benutzen das
angeblich hier im gesamten Land alles
wieder in Ordnung sei das ist
schlichtweg falsch
Vize Paul ronsheimer aus Kiew zur
sozialen tourismusdebatte die CDU-Chef
Friedrich Merz gestern abend hier bei
uns bei Bild losgetreten hat
[Musik]